parents this video is going to be a
little bit disturbing I want to tell you
right up front but there's Solutions at
the end of this video on what's going on
in schools and how you as a parent
should be involved there's six different
ways people are reacting to the madness
that's taking place in schools but I'm
going to give you solution and I'm going
to give you a challenge what you do with
it is on you but I highly recommend you
actually execute some of these things
we're talking about here if you get
value from this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and share it with other
parents like yourself let's get right
into it here's a video of an 11 year old
kid who goes to the school library
there's a book in the I'm not even going
to tell you what happens here listen to
what this kid sees reads in this book to
the board and watch the reaction I'm 11
years old and I go to middle school I'm
a sixth grader I was in the library and
this book was on a stand I'd like to
read you a page sixth grader my back
over my hips as I ask if we should take
off take our clothes off and he's saying
yes before I finish my sentence he's
pulling off my t-shirt laughing when I
can't undo his shirt buttons he's
undoing my belt I'm reaching into his
bedside drawer for a condom we're
kissing again we're rolling over
obviously you can see where this is
going I don't know if it's because we're
feeling especially emotional or just
tired or these past couple of weeks have
been too much but this reminds me so
much of the first time we had sex we
were both [__] terrified and the
whole thing was kind of terrible because
we didn't know what we were doing but it
was good too so good because we were a
mess of emotions and we were scared and
excited and everything felt new so this
sort of thing just sort of feels like
that Nick touches me like he's scared at
any minute
now this book was at my middle school
and it was on a stand when I rented it
out to show my dad it uh the librarian
asked if I wanted more and if I wanted a
graphic novel version wow and by the way
you you're gonna get the I'm gonna show
you the clip of what the father does
here but when you watch this here as a
parent you get different reactions I'm
having these conversations with a lot of
people nowadays whether it's you know my
dinner clients all these different
things they're upset they're angry
they're Furious but a lot of them feel
helpless but you're not helpless there's
six ways people are reacting to the
madness that's going on in schools
number one way parents oblivious they're
not involved they don't know what's
going on I'm too busy I'm trying to pay
the bills I can't get involved it's too
much for me you know it's just public
school I was a product of public school
it's all going to work itself out the
oblivious parents do not be surprised if
your kids get caught up in some of this
madness because no one's talking to them
about it the second type of parents that
are reacting to this they [__] they
complain they go and talk to other
friends but they do nothing about it all
talk but nothing happens the third thing
that parents are doing right now that
you can also do in your school is
they're saying this is so crazy they are
bitching they are complaining but
they're taking action and they're
running for school board now here's the
thing about running for school board I'm
going to give you some stats for you to
be thinking about and a lot of you I
want to challenge you to think about
running for school board some of you are
saying man it must be a lot of
responsibility me one running first why
would I would I ever get elected I'm not
a political person this isn't for me I'm
just a regular mother I totally get it
let me give you some stats over 90 of
things that take place in schools are
impacted by school boards if you're a
part of it you can impact over 90 of
things that happen in schools school
boards select the superintendent voter
turnout ready often is only between five
to ten percent of School Board elections
meaning if you run for it it's not like
100 of people are shown up anyways it's
only five to ten percent of your
philosophically in a place where maybe
you have more conservative beliefs and
you think the way their influence in the
kids is absolutely ludicrous you can go
talk to other mothers and other others I
said do you feel this way did you hear
about what happened what do you think
about this what do you think about that
I'm thinking about running do I have
your support do I have your support and
you're getting more people saying Mary
if you run Bobby if you run I would
definitely have your back we're also
upset about this thing here now you're
starting to recruit other people that
would be willing to vote for you because
you're concerned about the same issues
number four costs less than a thousand
dollars to run for School Board number
five very sellable campaign message
number six over seventy percent of
school board members say it was very
easy to get elected it's only one or two
meetings per month not time consuming
you do not have to disclose your
political affiliation at the ballot to
run 50 million children are impacted by
School Board decision let me say it
again over 50 million children are
impacted by School Board decisions
that's a big number and last but not
least 95 000 active school board members
in the U.S why not you go run for it if
you are so concerned about what's taking
place so now we have three different
reactions the oblivious the ones that
Vision complain then next one that says
there's no way I'm going to let this
happen I'm running for school board and
I'm gonna go recruit other parents and
talk about these types of issues
Wonderful by the way I want you to see
what this father does here to get
involved how bold he is and look how he
points out one of the manuals at the end
and what he says disturbing again I've
warned you disturbing but watch this
bold father concern about his son
oh boy
so I'm that kid's father okay good I was
asking for you yeah I'll take another
three minutes so that's my son okay okay
11 years old and went to his library and
found that by the entry door
of our library this is the smut that he
is finding all right I don't care
whether it's gay straight bisexual
whatever the terms are for all this
stuff doesn't need to be at our school
it doesn't need to be at my 11 year
old's library and then as far as
genderqueer
I've got a son in the high school as
well and this is
[__] We Know It All right we do not
need to be having literature that's
showing boys how to suck dick all right
this is a very very frustrated about it
okay and you may think that schools know
the best for our children you know who
know the best for our children the
parents are you upset are you frustrated
are you angry you getting the chills all
over your body you're kind of sitting
there saying I cannot believe this is
actually taking place well then do
something about it
do something about it half the battle of
challenges that takes place is When
leaders don't do anything about it you
are just as guilty if you allow this
madness to take place as the people that
are around that type of content to be in
schools because we gotta wake up me and
you there's a risk to staying quiet so
I'm challenging you while you're
watching this to do something about it
at the school board so three levels
oblivious [__] and complain go to the
board here's the next one number four is
private school with the right values and
principles I'm talking to a lot of
people right now they're asking about
private schools you can go on niche.com
you can look at all the schools find out
affiliation you know spiritual you know
catholic christian whatever may be all
over the place and you can interview
while you're interviewing these private
schools and you're talking to them ask
them what values and principles they
stand for these are things you ought to
be asking about right so you may say Pat
I can't afford to put my kids in private
school totally get it either find a way
to make extra money or number five homes
School them oh there's no way I can
homeschool my kids I just cannot
homeschool my kids no problem then last
but not least if you can't do any of
those things and you're watching the
saying I I still have to stay in public
school because I can't afford it find a
state and a district where it matches
your values and principles and research
the best public schools that have
certain values and principles that match
yours and move there yes move there it's
not supposed to be easy but move I hear
a lot of people that say things like
what do you mean move there I don't have
any money to move you think immigrants
had money when they moved to America how
much money you think we came to America
with what do you think my dad did when
we came here it was a cashier at 99 cent
store so what's the alternative staying
in Iran can you imagine yeah let's keep
our kids in Iran you know when the
Khomeini that it was a mess in Iran my
Mom and Dad aren't working the hell out
of here thank God they did we lived at a
refugee camp for a year and a half
before we made it to the states and then
we came here with nothing literally we
had nothing when we came out here so
it's not as big of a deal to move from
one state to another as it is to move
from a country you speak a whole
different language to a new country
you're going to move from California
Florida you still speak English you're
going to move from Chicago to Texas you
still speak English you're going to move
from New York to Tennessee you still
speak English but go do the research
because you know we're doing a live
podcast afterwards when the cigar lines
we're having a conversation this one
lady is sitting next to me and she's I
said how many kids you got she says I
got one kid so you got one kid and
you're a valutina she says yes so how
can it be if I can only have one kid you
know I'm always challenging people to
have more than one kid two three four
five kids if you have the resources you
have the money you want to have more
than one kid anyways we're having a nice
fun conversation together but the guy
next to her is a single guy 35 making a
lot of money and he said man I don't
want to get married because of this
because I said so what are you going to
do you're going to stay single the rest
of your life yeah what the hell's the
point of staying single the rest of your
life tell me what's exciting about that
what is the point of life why I'm making
money on this so how many do you need to
be like what do you think the goal of
life is yeah I got four kids okay the
relationship and the experience of how
much God has blessed me with these
forgive it's the four most amazing gifts
a man upstairs has given this regular
guy okay you and I if we're lucky enough
to have kids it's our responsibility to
lead them it's your responsibility to
Lita it's not easy if we don't bullying
comes in many different shapes and forms
and a lot of kids in America today are
being bullied and you and I need to
stand up and leave those are six
reactions aside from the first one which
they do nothing about it all the other
ones let's move let's lead let's do
something about it let's get louder in
boardrooms so our kids will be protected
so if you got value from this video give
it a thumbs up subscribe to the channel
and share it with other parents and I
got another video for you if you haven't
watched the public school crisis in
America if you've never seen it click
here to watch it take care everybody
bye-bye
foreign